there's one video that really seemed to
go viral from the whole world economic
Forum conference this year the elites
played it a little bit closer to the
chest you know they they did not uh
George Soros did not show up I I don't
think Bill Gates showed up they weren't
totally as wild as they often are in
their commentary with all the clips
because they know that we're sort of on
to them and we're paying more attention
but there was one clip that went viral
and this was the chairman of how do you
pronounce this company Simons is that
the name let's choose to pronounce it
that way who said that people need to
stop eating meat
and that in the future we're going to
have very different types of proteins
than meat it's a very important point
that you are addressing
um
my daughter
inspired me
and said that how can you
advocate for these serial carbon value
chains if you still eat meat
and so I stopped eating meat
now the math would say well you need to
stop eating meat 11 years to compensate
for a flight to Thailand
yes
but if a billion people stop eating meat
I tell you it has a big impact
not only does it have a big impact on
the current food system but it will also
Inspire innovation of Food Systems
and I predict that we will have proteins
not coming from
meat in the future
they will probably taste even better so
why are we trying to mimic meat if we
can have a better taste they will be
zero carbon and much healthier than the
kind of food that we eat today so this
is the main clip that's gone viral from
the world economic forum and what's
what's amazing to me is
no one has pointed out what this answer
was in reaction to
the question that I haven't really found
a clip of the the question as well uh
but I did I did get to see it as it was
happening
um because you you can stream all of
those this is one of the odd things
about the world economic Forum we think
of it as this highly secretive sort of
Kabbalah people they live stream most of
their events and the question that was
asked specifically referenced
eating bugs the question that was asked
was about how we can get people to move
away from eating meat and go toward a
more vegetarian or vegan or even
um edible insects diets and and his
answer the the CEO of this company or
chairman rather very important company
uh was
oh yes of course that's what we have to
do we need a billion people to stop
eating meat and the proteins of the
future they're not going to come from
meat they're gonna they're gonna taste
much better
specifically in reaction to a question
that mentions edible insects so when we
hear that the davo said it's talking
about you will eat the bugs you will
live in zipade you will owe nothing and
be happy
they mean that
they mean that even at the conference
where they were clearly trying to
downplay a lot of their more ambitious
projects that is clearly something that
they have in mind and if you if you
listen to that guy I don't think that
that guy has bad intentions I think that
guy probably has very good intentions I
think he genuinely believes that is a
virtuous thing to do
is this is the the other fact of the the
great reset and the plans of the liberal
Elites who want to remake the world
after their own image
they believe that they were doing the
right thing and their plan makes sense
if you start with the premise that there
is no God there is no soul there is no
such thing as dignity we're all just
kind of random products of evolution and
we're all going to get wiped out by the
sun monster if we don't stop living like
dignified human beings if you start with
all those premises you're going to end
up at that conclusion it's like what
always happens in logic garbage in
garbage
the world economic forum
the world economic Forum which just
concluded last week in Davos Switzerland
had a panel on the future of work
and
the
the future of work
looks really Pleasant for the elites if
you ask the world economic forum
the uh the world economic Forum panel
and the future of the work week
suggested that
uh perhaps the elites need more time off
not everybody needs more time off but
the elites need more time off
there was an international study that
showed that revenues actually Rose for
companies that cut down their work week
from five days to four days
and this is true really only for the
upper class the Dutch employment
Minister karyanvan genip acknowledged
that the four day work week conversation
remains quote very much a discussion for
the upper class
uh the uh this is now a year after
virtual commutes became commonplace for
white-collar employees uh 67 percent of
these white-collar employees were able
to work from home exclusively
now this would be compared to say
teachers 48 of Educators were able to
work from home exclusively 35 of
healthcare professionals were able to
work from home exclusively which seems
kind of high to me but I guess people do
telemedicine
and then basically zero percent of
service employees are able to work from
home exclusively because they have to do
real jobs with their bodies in time and
space so that all the white collar
people can stay at home
as a technical matter I guess this makes
sense
but
as a spiritual matter this is a very
very bad idea and the reason it's a bad
idea is not because white collar workers
who are telecommuting on their laptops
while they're in their pajamas it's not
because that is necessarily going to
diminish profits for a company or tick
down GDP for a country the reason that
this is a very bad idea is because Idle
Hands Are The Devil's Playground
the reason this is a bad idea is because
it accelerates a very bad Trend that
we've been seeing in our culture now for
years which is a trend away from
physical reality
it's a trend away from acknowledging
that that we are bodies as well as Souls
you see that particularly expressed in
transgenderism transgenderism says my
body has nothing to do with who I am I'm
purely metaphysical so I might look like
a boy but I'm really a girl
you see this in
the move away from real social contact
during the the lockdowns we weren't
allowed to hug our loved ones well
that's okay we can just zoom with them
let's have zoom drinks and zoom dinner
that's obviously not as satisfying
and because when people work from home
maybe they're more efficient in some
ways but they've got a lot of downtime
and they don't get dressed and they say
well what does it matter if I get
dressed I can wear sweatpants and socks
all day because no one really cares well
it matters because you are in part a
body and you live in time and space and
so if you treat yourself like a big just
lunk of meat then you're going to behave
like a big lunk of meat and not like a
dignified human being as you as you
should
this is especially worrisome for the
elites because the elites are extremely
decadent you know their idea of fighting
Injustice around the world is to fly to
an Alpine Swiss Resort
and go skiing for a few days and eat
fancy meals and drink fancy drinks
hobnobbing with the richest and most
powerful people on earth
okay if the decadence
is an occupational hazard for these
sorts of people and now they're saying
we need to be a little bit more decadent
well you poor little people go out there
you bring me my filet mignon you deliver
it on Uber Eats and then you go back and
you eat your bugs I don't know what
accent that is I'm not sure exactly but
I don't it's just a vague kind of
Cosmopolitan accent
it's a very bad idea everybody
especially the elites need to be
actively involved there's there's no
neutrality this is something we've
talked about on the show a lot there's
no neutrality in speech there's no
neutrality in politics there's no
neutrality in the physical world you've
always got to be doing something the
question is what are you doing are you
spending time playing with your kids are
you spending time working building up a
business are you spending time fixing up
the house or are you spending time
loafing around and you know just getting
drunk and and indulging your lusts there
was an article that showed that there
were apparently hundreds and hundreds of
high-class prostitutes who are
descending on on Davos for the
conference are you what are you doing
what are you doing
if anybody
needs to remain more occupied not less I
think it is those Elites the rest of the
show continues now I'm very happy now
that we're live totally live again
to have the member block back you do not
want to miss it okay it's music Monday
baby we're listening to some cool fast
hip Tunes I don't even know what the
tune is yet I'll read the I'll read the
sheet The Producers left me
on the member block become a member
right now use code Knowles kwles at
checkout for two months free on all
annual plans we'll see you over there
[Music]
foreign